Please hands up.
I don't know which one it's for. I'll
find
Time is up. Please bring your quizzes in
if they're out there still.
There we go.
I saw you and I started.
Okay.
You remember at the start of this class?
You remember at the start of this class
I said that the world can shift under
you while the class is in motion. Right?
Many of you did your valuations before
last Thursday. Right? You valued your
company. There's a price of the company
and you turned in your value. Some of
you might have felt more secure than
others with a story, a value, a
price. And maybe you felt pretty good on
Wednesday. I'm not sure how you feel
today, but two days can make a
difference, right? We last met last
Wednesday after the class ended. I
taught my evening, the evening class for
the undergraduates. I got on a flight to
Santiago. I get on the plane. I'm
checking the Yankee score, which is
probably the only thing I'm interested
in, when a new story crosses my I mean
hits my phone, and I'm pissed off
because I'm watching the Yankee game.
It's right in
MLB.com. And the new story, of course,
was about the tariff
announcement. Now, we've been expecting
tariffs all year, right? Because fact,
if you listen to Trump, he's been
talking about tariffs for 40
years. So, you're saying, "What's the
surprise?" The surprise I think was
what? That there were tariffs. So what
is it about the Wednesday announcement
that shook people up so much?
Sorry. What?
First it's breath, right? Everybody gets
it. No, there's the map. You're saying,
"Oh, what happened in North America?"
That's because Canada and Mexico have
already been tariffs. So they're off the
table. The big chunk of over Asia is
Russia, which at least in theory is
under sanctions, so it doesn't need
tariffs. It's tariffs across the world.
That's the first. Second is did any of
you check the magnitude of the tariffs?
These are not 5% 10%. They're
monstrously large for some
countries. And the third is the way the
tariffs got
assessed, right? What's the basis for
the tariffs? It was it was not based on
recip like the trade deficit divided by
two, which is it's on a percentage
basis, right? But the divided by two
fine but on a percentage basis which
means smaller countries like Vietnam
will have a bigger percentage trade
deficit than larger countries. So it's
broad it's wide and the problem with
basing it on trade def trade deficits is
already some countries have talked about
cutting tariffs to zero. The you can cut
tariffs to zero but the trade deficit
won't go away still right. So that's
almost an unfixable problem. And if this
ba remains a basis for tariffs, there's
going to be no easy walking it
back at least without losing
face. So it happened Wednesday. Luckily
for me, I lost my internet connection
once I got in the air. Okay, which is a
blessing sometimes. Maybe you should
just go on a flight for the next six
months. Okay, maybe one of those space,
you know, that spaceship that those
those guys got trapped in, that's where
you want to go for the next 6 months
because clearly things are going to
happen, right? But on Thursday and
Friday, markets melted down. I won't get
take you through, but you know, I spent
the last I started after I finished your
office hours at 6:00 p.m. I started
writing this thing at midnight. I
finally said, I'm exhausted. I'm just
going to bed. But this morning I think
I'm pretty close to complete. So I'm
going to put it up later today. But I'll
give you a preview. Of course we looked
at the indices. You can see
already the one of the one of the things
about teaching evaluation classes. I
don't have the luxury of engaging in
abstractions. This is the real world and
I can't get around it. So, I want to
spend at least the 10 first 10 or 15
minutes just talking about Thursday and
Friday cuz you're all affected by it in
terms of your valuations and potentially
your jobs,
right? I scared you already. I said, "Oh
my god, I have a job offer already." But
this is in a sense earthshattering,
earth shaking in terms of what it can
do. So that's what but the problem with
indices is there a subset of companies.
So during co one of the things I started
doing on a weekly basis is downloading
the market cap of every stock from S&P
capital IQ and just
aggregating. So first thing I aggregated
based ros on region I wanted to see was
the pain spread out and if you look
across regions the worst hit part of the
world in terms and this surprised me is
what I call small Asia don't take that
as an insult it's Asia without India
China and
Japan had the biggest hit on Thursday
and Friday India and China actually look
pretty good but remember their markets
closed before the US Friday market so I
haven't looked today because again I
choose not to look while I'm writing the
post because it can contaminate what
you're writing. But my guess is that the
morning in China was probably not a
great start. So that might just be a
lagged effect. So it's across the globe.
You see the percentage drop off and then
I started slicing and dicing the data.
And I'm going to stay with the US data
for this because I want to look at hey
where was the damage the greatest? If
this were panic
selling, when you look at the data, what
should you expect to see? What kinds of
companies should go down the most? What
kinds should go down the and and which
one should not benefit go down the
least? Where should the money go
from
risky non-cash yielding companies to
save? So basic and at first side when
you look across sector there's some
backing for that safety there. If you
look at the sector that did the best
during this period, you know, during
those so I'm focused on just on this on
the last week because that's the week of
the you know you see
utilities and consumer staples which
kind of makes sense right staples you
need in recessions and good times and
bad times and the worst performing
sector was actually in percentage terms
but technology left almost one point if
you look at the chain just in the
technology lost $1.8 trillion in market
cap just in the in the last week. If you
slice based on market cap again I wanted
to see was small companies hurt more
large here there was almost no
difference small and large across the
board you saw damage across the board if
you break down companies based on P
ratio where low P ratio stocks
performing well at least marginally the
lowest P ratio stocks were down only 8%.
Kind of sky to say only 8%. High PE
stocks were down about 11%. So there's
some mild backing for a risk effect. No
joke. But then I broke companies down by
debt. I looked at debt to broke down by
decile. Almost no difference. In fact,
lightly levered companies actually did
worse than highly levered companies.
Maybe that's got the technology overlay
on it trying to drive
it. And finally, I wanted to see whether
dividend paying stocks were worse
affected. There's no
difference. This is all leading
somewhere because you're looking for
clues as to what exactly is
happening. So final question I asked
was, is this just an over, you know,
some of the stocks that got bid up the
most last year? I broke down stocks
based on percentage change last year. So
it's like a momentum play. Was it a
reversal? Look at the last column. Not
really.
The bottom line is you look across
stocks. This looks more like an orderly
retreat than a complete panic. The
complete panic you're going to see the
shifts across. You're not seeing that at
least on it's very early in the process
but you're not seeing it there.
Question. Yeah. one party that Billman
was talking about how a lot of this
might just be odd shops institutional
investors and funds that are essentially
have parameters and then once they get
below those it could be right a lot of
it's how do you kind of set well that'll
happen if it's happening it'll happen on
a continuous basis right lever investors
investors needing to get out fund flows
you're passive investing passive
investing remember is a momentum feeder
right the upside it pushes up momentum
on the downside you're going extract
your money across the board based on
market cap, right? So the same things
that help you and that's why I've never
built it, you know, bought into the
story that some passive investing just
pushes markets up. It feeds momentum in
both directions and we're seeing it feed
in in the other direction. So maybe
that's what you know indirectly is
driving institutional investing and
pulling back is funds leaving their I
mean they're losing money from their
clients and they got to pull it out of
the market. So then from like our
perspective I have invested into X. Are
you still going to probably sit on that?
We'll talk about it. We could go
fundamentals and then maybe I because I
think no one and this is why I think
it's dangerous to have one recipe for
everybody because I I'll talk about the
three things that you have to look
inward to decide what to do next. I did
look at the max 7 always in there and uh
leading into last week they were already
down collectively about 15% this
year. Last week they lost another 10%.
So last week was nothing. They were just
like the rest of the market but the
leading ind but just to give you
perspective that's $1.55 trillion in
market cap lost just in the last week by
the max 7. So that's what the equity
markets look like. Damage across the
board, very little differentiation
across different
classes. Now, of course, you know, when
you have crisis, you sell stocks, you
got if you remember, some of this money
that's disappearing, it's gone forever.
It's not coming back. It just disappears
into whiff of air. It's market trillions
of market. It's not It's not like people
extracted 5.5 trillion from these stocks
and they're putting them elsewhere. It
just disappears into thin air. Some of
it is going to turn into cash. That cash
has to go somewhere. And usually in a
crisis, where does it go? It goes to a
place of safety. And for better or
worse, US treasuries still remain that
place. And if you look at what happened
on Thursday and Friday, you see rates
coming down, but again, not by the
magnitude expect. Table rates actually
changed hardly. You know, they were like
0.04%. The other rates, the longerterm
rates did drop, but by like 0.25. to
5.3%. In most crises, the drops you see
in the treasury market tend to be much
much larger in the yields. You're not
seeing that
yet. Yes.
Since tariffs are going back inflation
as well and you had three years of high
inflation right now. Nobody's talking
about thinking even thinking about
inflation that will come right instead
of going to the safe haven of 10 years
they might go to money markets and since
that has no money where do money markets
invest? months, but that's not going to
drive down because it has No, no, no,
no. What do you mean? If that much money
goes to money markets, goes from the
three-month ebooks, it'll definitely
drive down the yield. There's not much
money going into the 3month right now.
That could very quickly change if this
continues. But right now, you're not
seeing the funds flow which you normally
see into a three-month table because you
take a I mean, I'll show you some of the
other crises. the table rate just
collapses during a crisis because of
cash know from all those money market
funds in the aggregate now push it
down and might push it down below
inflation in the near term because
that's what panic buying
does then I looked at three very
desperate investments I'm not going to
call them assets oil and bitcoin right
oil is my standin for commodities
basically it's capturing what the
investors are thinking about the real
economy in the near term and oil prices
are down. In fact, this morning they
fell below $60. If any of you valing oil
companies, you better revisit your
valuation because last Wednesday this
was
$78. Now it's 59. Your oil company might
have become a distress company. That
money losing company you have in your
group. Well, guess what? You just have a
money losing company by accident, right?
Gold I pick because it is a collectible
of long longstanding. Whenever you have
a crisis, gold held its own last week,
but there was no surge. Again, it feeds
into if this is
panic selling, you're not seeing it show
up in the usual panic assets. And
Bitcoin actually surprised me. I mean,
people present it as a collectible, but
for the last 15 years, you know what the
track record of Bitcoin has been during
crisis?
October, I'm going to show you the COVID
crisis. February 14th through March
23rd, stocks went down
33%. What did Bitcoin do, Michael? I
think it went down even more than that.
57%. Down 57%. Stocks came back 45% in
the next 9 months. Bitcoin was up 80%.
It's like a very risky stock, which is
the exact opposite of what you want in a
good collectible. For the first crisis
in its lifetime, Bitcoin actually held
its own on Thursday. that too can very
quickly start to shift. I don't know
what the open trade was today, but at
least for those two days, it was a
decent collectible. This might be the
the epigraph you write on Bitcoin's
tombstone did really well for two days
in April of 2025, but it did do well on
Thursday and Friday 2025.
So, you know, you can pass, you can go
through it and make your own judgments,
but as I look at it for the moment at
least, and it's very early in this game,
it looks like there's a lot of selling.
It's being driven by people reassessing
what they think about equities for good
reason. Could it become panic selling
very quickly, right? Panic sets in. You
know, right now it hasn't happened yet,
but this bears watching. So, I'm going
to probably regret saying this, but
every Friday for the next few weeks,
which could stretch into the year, I
will revisit the numbers because the
only way to deal with this is to
actually let the numbers tell you where
you are. So, I'm going to revisit all
those tables every week for the next in
the case of COVID, I started on February
14th of 2020. I didn't stop till
November of 2020. So this is like a
sentence in prison, but it's something
you have to do during a crisis. So now
I'm going to step back because every
time in a crisis you get caught up in
what do we do? So let's look at a
typical crisis and how it unfolds. I
call this my crisis
cycle. There's usually a trigger, right?
Something that sets it the crisis off.
The trigger can be as we saw with 2008
the Leman
collapse in 2020. the co but every
usually that trigger is not completely
unexpected. Were there signs that the
financial service business was in
trouble before Leman went
under? Bear Sterns floated very closely
as they managed to evade that. So that
you know there are series of things that
can happen but the trigger is an event
can be economic, it can be political, it
can be
financial and investors react to that
event.
Now, it's easy to look back with
hindsight and say those crazy investors,
they were overreacting, underreacting.
You have to react in the moment,
right? And I mean, I respect what
markets do in crisis. They try their
best. Sometimes they overshoot,
sometimes they undershoot, but they
don't do what people on CNBC do, which
is talk and talk and talk, and nobody
ever does anything. They buy or they
sell. So, I respect that because it's
real action.
And what's your only thing you control
as an investor? So the new story has
come out about the tariffs. What's the
only thing you control? Okay, whether
you buy or sell the price, right? And if
you're afraid, what happens? You demand
a higher price for risk. You sell your
stocks until you get to that reasonable
return. And you usually take the money
and move it to someplace safer. So
that's a first
reaction. That's day one, day two. But
then there are aftershocks. It's like an
earthquake. What are the aftershocks?
Then initial event sets off other events
either in counter to the original event
the case of tariffs. Now it'll play out
either as some country saying we're
going to drop our tariffs. The EU this
morning announced that they would be
willing to drop their tariffs to 0%. Or
you could have what China did which is
we're going to raise our tariffs. So
both things can play out. Good news,
there was a rumor this morning that the
tariffs might be paused. The market
jumped up 3%. So you're going to see
more and more of that happen over the
next few days because you're an edge.
This becomes the basis for the market.
Will it play out in the real economy? Of
course it will. How can it not? Right?
That same fear factor that's affecting
investors, affecting consumers,
businesses. Will it cause a recession?
Maybe, maybe not. But there will be an
economic slowdown. That economic
slowdown has one bonus which is it'll
dampen inflation. So even though there
might be a tariff effect, there is this
lesser inflation. So there will be a
real economic effect. Why do we care as
investors? Because it'll affect
earnings and through earnings and cash
flows. It'll affect our value. Will
there be a long-term effect? Depends on
the original events. Sometimes they do,
sometimes they don't. If it's a
long-term effect, you reset your
expectations about real growth and
inflation going forward because of the
event, which then feeds back again into
financial
markets. So, I'll take you back to 2008.
The triggering event was the Lehman
collapse on September 13th and 14th, the
weekend leading into September 15th.
Woke up to September 15th, the market
reacted and over the next few weeks, the
market lost the stock prices dropped by
28%. Again, I'm going to break down the
the first two weeks versus the longer
period. The first two weeks after the
Leman collapse, stocks dropped 12%. In
the subsequent weeks, it dropped another
16%. Treasury rates starting the process
3.72%, by the time this process played
out, they were down to 2.2%.
No, basic and tre and and that was
across the treasury spectrum. There was
a you know and there were aftershocks
after Lehman. I mean I remember weeks
when there were rumors that Morgan
Stanley would not make it through the
end of the week that Goldman Sachs would
not make it through the end of the week.
Luckily those rumors didn't play out but
there was a real economic effect. We
entered a recession. The recession was
deep and fairly painful. Unemployment
hit 10% by
2009. And did the 2008 crisis have
long-term real economic implications? It
took almost 5 years to get back to
precrisis levels in terms of earnings
and economic
activity. And then people wrote a
postcript about the 2008 crisis. What
did they
conclude? That it was banks behaving
badly and ratings agencies not doing
their job. and that if regulators did a
better job on that we would not have had
it. One of the things I'm going to argue
is the postcripts that are written after
many crises are based on a sample size
of one and they often deal with the
symptoms rather than the causes. But
that was the 2008
crisis. September 12th of 2008 I started
estimating the implied equity risk
premium every day. That's the other
thing I do during the crisis is I start
doing this every day just for my own
sanity.
or
insanity. So there's the implied equity
risk premium start of the crisis. There
was a day in November where the implied
equity risk premium for the US that
makes in fact that's exactly why I call
this the price of risk. You're afraid
you push up the price of risk. You push
on at the end of the year the implied
equity risk premium for US equities was
6.43%. It did not get back to pre208
levels till last year. 16 years to make
it back and now it's back again back up
above
5%. What about 2020? February 14th, we
get a new story out of Italy saying they
found some COVID cases in Italy and they
could not connect those cases to either
China or cruise ships which until then
we assumed were the places you had to go
to get CO. That was the delusion we
operated under. That of course triggered
the COVID crisis and in the next six
weeks the S&P 500 lost 33% of its value.
Treasury rates were already low coming
into the crisis. 1.6% dropped to 76% a
historic low. Were there aftershocks?
Every week there stories of health
crisis, hospitals that couldn't handle
it, businesses that were shutting
down. The market kind of played out. Was
there real economic impact in the
quarter that the economy shut down?
Obviously earnings collapsed that
quarter unemployment I think that didn't
even stop reporting the numbers because
it became pointless. It was like 30%
plus because you know everybody was
collecting unemployment and it looked
like we were in for the long term but
this was almost magical and perhaps not
so magical when you think about the
multi-trillion dollar government support
systems that kicked into place by
September.
the economy was starting to roll back
into place. Unemployment was starting to
come down. It didn't fully come down
till 2021 and 2022. But this one, the
long-term effects didn't seem to
persist. And what's a postcript from
CO? Governments and central banks can
stop these problems if they step in and
act better. Again, as I said, the
postcripts often draw the wrong
conclusion, but that's a conclusion that
people drew out of
CO. And as with 2008, I computed the
equity risk premium every day during CO
started at February 14th at 4.4%.
There's March 23rd of 2020, it hit
7.75%. But the difference here is by
September, it was back to pre crisis
levels.
It's very early in the game. So I I as I
said with postmortems I think the
problem is we it's like statistics. We
have a sample size of one. Every crisis
a sample size of one and we extrapolate
lessons we shouldn't. Would investors
when you show those graphs to investors
you know what the reaction is? Markets
always come back right look they came
back. Therefore what should you do if
you're a contrarian investor with a long
time horizon? You should be buying
stocks now because look at those graphs.
And here's the problem. Just because a
catastrophe did not occurred during that
crisis doesn't mean that the probability
of a catastrophe occurring was always
zero. 2008 there was a very real chance
that we could have gone into a global
financial
meltdown. It didn't happen. But the fact
that it didn't happen doesn't mean that
the probability of it not with co there
was a very real chance we shut the
global economy down. We could not have
we were not able to start it back up
again. That's why we charge an equity
risk premium because we hope and pray
that we don't see that catastrophe
during our
lifetimes. But if you look at the last
300 years of equity returns, somebody
sent me this graph. It actually is very
close to the debond rate because you
have enough catastrophes in a 300-year
period that it eats away that upside you
saw. Luckily, none of us will live to be
300 years
old. But hopefully we won't see that
catastrophe in our lifetime because if
300 years what it takes to get back to
steady state, if we have that
catastrophe, we won't make it back in
our lifetime to where we were before the
catastrophe. Yeah. Even if you're in
that risk, that probability of down the
possibility of the Fed bailing you out,
not you, but you know, investors
probably do, but the question is the
problem is too big for even what can the
Fed do if real economic growth comes to
a standill, right? There's some maybe
the co problem was
particularly susceptible to the Fed
being able to fix it because it was hey
we'll give you enough money till the
economy starts rolling again. I'm not
sure in 2008 the Fed could have done
much and it tried right. It tried but it
didn't work that well. So maybe the Fed
can do things in some crises but not in
others.
Yes. Do you think that like we hit a
point like I'm gonna like roll back
everything like just shaken too much
confidence that like table investors are
very very resilient. We've learned to
since
2008 I think that what it'll do is
create more volatility around what
exactly I it's not that the that the
roll back by itself is the issue. It's
will there be a roll forward roll back
roll forward. This is not a, you know,
game where you say roll back. Trust us,
we're not coming back to this again.
This is something where you're going to
see this part of all markets will learn
to live with it, but it'll take a while
and it'll show up maybe as lower stock
prices and higher equity risk premiums
in the long term for us to be okay with
it. So, we're two days into this crisis.
Today's day three, right? Thursday,
Friday, Monday. So, it's a little early
to be passing judgment. We're through
the first two phases. There's a tariff
announcement the first two days. There's
more to come. Will there be aftershocks?
Yeah, Friday you had chi China
countering. Today you've got the
opposite. Maybe some good news coming
out from some countries saying, you
know, but this is going to be the way of
the world for the for the next few
weeks, even months, right? There will be
a real economic impact that's almost
undeniable. there'll be a slowing. You
know, the probability of a recession has
I mean when people assess that has got
has almost doubled since last
Wednesday. Will it mean we're going to
be in a recession? Not necessarily. The
numbers haven't come rolling through
yet. But there will be a slowing of the
economy. Perhaps inflation will leave
center states. For the last three years,
since 2022, inflation's been this, hey,
I want to be the star. I want to be the
star. Maybe this will take the focus of
inflation. Maybe that's the only good
thing that comes out of
this. The long-term
impact, I mean, let's face
it, the global economy has benefited
from free trade. Now, we can argue that
those benefits have been unfairly se,
you know, unfairly separated out to
different groups. But you take you make
it more difficult to conduct global
trade which I think this process will
global economic growth will come
down the pie will get smaller but here's
where I think it
becomes tricky because the pie could get
smaller but the aortionment of the pie
can change because of this. Now what
I've what I'm hearing from the White
House as a defense is not about markets.
It's about hey we want the pie to be a
portion differently and for you know for
better or worse that capital has taken
too large a slice of the pie over the
last four decades and I think that's
absolutely true by capital I mean equity
market shareholders and that maybe the
smaller pie there will be groups that
actually come out be better better off
with the smaller pie than with the
larger one that's what we don't know and
anybody who claims differently I think
it's just barking up a tree. I don't see
how you can tell me that it's not going
to
happen. So, it's early in the process,
but I'm going to be estimating implied
equity risk pre end of every day for the
next foresee for the foreseeable future.
So, this graph is just very early. This
is how the co graph started. I was
teaching on February 14th and February
21st. I remember putting this graph up
saying it's three days in. Let's see
where this goes. We're three day we're
two days in and every day I'm going to
update this graph and perhaps by May 6 a
graph will start to take form in a in a
way that hopefully doesn't look like 8%
equity risk premiums by the time we get
there because that translates into 25 30
35%
corrections. But that's so far where we
are. E- bond rates have drifted down.
Equity risk premiums are now 5.08%
Friday close. So, I don't know what
it'll be by the end of today, but no,
it's a it's a table I will keep updating
through and and of course there will be
aftershocks. There will be economic
effects real short and long term. And
that's still what we're watching.
And now of course one of the things I
would strongly suggest you do is stop
watching
CNBC because I will predict there'll be
three groups of experts who will show
up. So the next time you see an expert
play it for know play it like a drinking
game right expert which group do I put
in. The first is with the I told you so
group I told you so this was going to
come to a bad end. I told you so you're
going to hell. You know, so this is of
course a group that wags its finger and
says this is or you deserve it, you
investors, you've been lazy and sloppy
and punishment is coming. You know,
they're like that guy on Time Square. I
don't know whether he's still there who
says you're going to hell. You're going
to hell. You know, he reads, you know,
and they've been saying that. So when
you see one of these one of these people
show up on CNBC saying, "I saw this
coming."
Go back and look at their history to see
how long they've been telling you that
they've seen this coming. And most of
them have been doing this for more than
a decade. Then ask yourself a question.
If you'd listened to them right from the
beginning and you'd gone into cash when
they told you this was coming, would you
be better off than somebody who actually
didn't see it coming, went through the
crash and dealt with it, right? So they
I told you so the most obnoxious group
of all like that that group will come to
the surface right now. the
bubblers. The second group is the exact
opposite. They're the knee-jerk
contrarians. You should buy. Why?
Because everything is down. That that's
the entire argument. Stock prices are
down a lot, so it must be a
buy. And the third group is this hand
ringing group of there's uncertainty on
the one side, the other hand, the third
hand, the fourth hand. This is the
market strategist group. they will get
on there and by the time they're done 5
minutes later, you don't know whether
they told you the markets are going to
go up, down, or just stay where they
were. But if you listen to them, you
should just sit on your hands till the
uncertainty passes and then you can do
neat stuff because you could be waiting
forever to do this. So here's, you know,
and this goes back to the early
question. What should I do today? I'm
going to tell you what I would do, but I
want you to look inward at these three
things because they'll determine what
you should do. First, if you need cash
in the near term, don't be waiting. In
fact, leave the class right now. Go sell
your stock, convert to cash because the
most dangerous thing you can do is if
you need cash 2 or 3 months from now, is
wait for a better time. Who knows what
two months from now bring. So cash needs
and time horizon are bundled up. So if
you need if you don't need cash, you
have the
luxury of waiting, but you might choose
not to, right? But at least you have the
luxury of waiting. Second, your macro
views have to come in. And don't hide
behind, I'm not a macroeconomist. I
don't know what's coming. This is
nothing to do with economics. It's game
theory, right? Basically, you've got one
move. You're going to have counter
moves. I think a really good poker
player is probably in a better position
to forecast what's coming than a
macroeconomist because there are three
ways this can play out. It can be a
full-blown trade war, in which case, God
help us. It can be a partial trade war
with some countries where other
countries kind of settle in or third it
can be this it'll go away clearing of
the air the tariffs go back on to the
back burner there's a pause I think the
second scenario is the most likely one
from my perspective but I think the
first and the third still remain on the
table and finally should depend on your
investment philosophy which is basically
what you think about markets where you
think they make
mistakes and what your personal makeup
purpose and I teach a class in western
philosophy which I've never taught at
Stern but there's a online version you
can see where I say look the right
philosophy for you is the one that best
fits
you so what works for you might not work
for me so here's what I plan to do I
plan to compute the RP every
day for as long as needed hopefully not
that long but not that's out of my hands
second I 37 companies in my portfolio.
I've got to go back and revalue all of
them, right?
Because this can change their value.
Perhaps in good ways for some companies,
bad and others. And maybe I might have
to prune some of those companies, not
because the price has gone down, but
because the value's gone down even more.
I was comfortable with the companies in
my portfolio on Wednesday before this
hit. comfortable in the sense that they
were still undervalued or not overvalued
enough for me to pull the trigger. That
might have
changed. Third, and this is going to be
a tough one. I can't stop investing just
because it's a
crisis. Some of you value companies that
you think aren't great companies, but
they're not great investments. What
separates them? The price.
right now. Three weeks ago when I wrote
about uh
globalization and Tesla, I talked about
the fact that I was selling Tesla
because of a bunch of reasons. I'd sold
Tesla already, but I said I wanted BYD
in my portfolio and I valued BYD and and
I said at the ADR the price was too high
for me to buy BYD. I did on that day put
in a limit buy for BYD at $5 below my
value.
I didn't think there was even the
slightest
chance it would get made. But hey, no
harm. Look, you know, just putting it
out there. It's a limit buy. It's good
till cancelled. And last week when I
valued Marcato Libra, I was
extraordinarily impressed by the
company. I initially thought it was like
Amazon, but the closer you look at it,
this is more than an Amazon. It's got
all of the features of Amazon, the
retail space. And with Marcado Pavo,
they've got a full-fledged I thought
initially a payment processing system,
but it looks like a bank and a mutual
fund on the other
side. I valued at 1,600 was trading at
2,200. I wish it were cheaper and I
didn't put the limit by at 1500 on
Wednesday before I
left. On Friday, I check the price. It's
down to 1,800. Two Fridays is all I need
like last Friday and it becomes a buy.
So the reason I put limit buys is if you
have to make the buy decision, you will
not do
it. It's terrifying actually buying
shares. You get to that last stage in
the trade is are you sure? And you will
leave the the screen and go to another
screen and hope the screen freezes
before you have to come back so you
don't have to buy. I want to take that
decision out of my hands.
So if you have great companies, I mean,
I've heard people complain about not
owning the Mag
7, this is your chance.
You don't have to buy it at today's
price, but value each of
them. You know, Amazon might be cheap
now and this might be your chance to
buy. So danger plus opportunity. And I
think that in many ways it's tough to
do, but I and finally, I don't plan to
let this take over my life.
So, I'm going to go back to San Diego on
Thursday. My daughter's having a baby
shower on Saturday. I to fully enjoy the
baby
shower. And my granddaughter has a
birthday on Sunday. That's going to be
priority one. I take the dog for a walk.
I won't even look at markets on
Thursday, Friday, Saturday, and Sunday.
Monday, I'll have no choice because I
have to teach the class
again. But I will do the implied equity
at the end of every day, even on
Thursday and Friday. But I think
that if you put your life on hold
because markets are chaotic. I mean if
this is your life, you have to trade.
You have no choice. But the essence of
investing is you got to pass the sleep
test. You know what? I've been sleeping
well. I slept Wednesday night, Thursday
night. Even know Wednesday night I was
in a plane, but I still slept Thursday
night, Friday night. So no, I so far I
haven't lost any sleep. I've lost some
money on my portfolio, but I've not lost
sleep. And that's a win for me. So,
whatever you do, you got to pass the
sleep test after you're done. So, that's
your that'll be a test. If you do
something and you're lying awake at
night and saying, "I wonder what my
portfolio will do tomorrow." You fail
the sleep
test. It's actually a great way to make
sure that it's, you know, so do what you
have to do. Yep. What would have to
happen in the market for you to lose
weight?
what would have to happen and if it's
happened there's losing faith would be
irrelevant at that point right if it
completely collapses and there's nothing
that'll make me come back from it right
so I think the events that will cause
you to completely lose faith are the
events where you it's hard to be a hands
anyway so what's the point of worrying
about it yes uh with the recent crash in
the market and tariffs like what exactly
are you like is it 10% sufficient to
call it a crash I I'm also trying to say
what variables are you trying to
readjust your models like growth rates
is what are the only variables that
control value right let's step back
right and that's actually a good
exercise how does how do all these
events show up in your value through
revenue growth margins reinvestment and
risk that's the advantage of having
parsimmonious models is it gives you
focus everything that's happening out
there has to show up in one or more of
those so play it through your company
right how will a tariff war affect my
revenue revenue growth, my margins, my
reinvestment and my risk. For some of
you, the effect is going to be dramatic.
Take Boeing, right? At least three of
you are valing Boeing. This could be a
major shift because if you're Boeing and
you derive the bulk of your revenues
from outside the US, God only knows
where you get the parts for your
aircraft. You're incredibly
exposed. Your craft foods, maybe you're
not as exposed, right? Even though
you're a global company. So I think the
effects are going to be disparit by the
time you play them out. But that's
assuming we know how the endgame is
going to be for terrorists themselves.
But always kind of bring it back to
those basics because otherwise it's so
easy to be reactive and
distracted. So let's uh I left you with
perhaps it's good timing because we're
talking about is the market overpriced,
right? the and we were looking at PE
ratios and I said L depends the
alternative here's what I'm going to do
try to address that question maybe we
can put today's numbers in to see if we
can answer the question I took the price
earnings ratio and I inverted it you
know the advantage of inverting the
price earnings ratio is remember the
price earnings ratio is not cannot be
calculated when earnings are negative
the earnings to price ratio works even
when earnings are negative you get a
negative number but it actually makes
sense
It's a much more robust multiple than P
ratio. It's called earnings yield. So
there's the earnings to price ratio.
That's the red line. The green line is
the 10ear T bond rate. Let me just pause
with that. Do those two look like they
move
together for the most part. You say,
"What's this purple line?" It's the
difference between the 10-year bond rate
and the threemonth
rate. What am I measuring with that
yield inversion? The slope of the yield
curve, right? If that number is a big
positive number, I have an upward
sloping yield curve. If that number is
zero, I have a flat yield curve. That
number is negative, I have a downward
sloping yield curve. You think, who
cares? We'll talk about why that might
affect PE ratio. So, I'm looking at the
level of rates and the slope of the
yield curve. See, the first thing I did
was what every statistics class teaches
you to do is to calculate the
correlations. Correlation in earnings
yield and T-bond rate is 69. What does
that tell me? Higher T- bond rates
translate into higher earnings to price
ratios. I know it's tough to do, but
invert in your mind, a high earnings to
price ratio means low PE ratio. So T-
bond rates rise, PE ratios decrease.
Make
sense? And at least in terms of the
sign, the more upward sloping the yield
curve, the lower the earnings to price
ratio, which means a higher P ratio. So
why is an upward sloping yield curve
better for stocks?
Who cares what the yield curve looks
like? Yeah.
The economy. In other words,
historically the slope of the yield
curve has become a standin for what the
economy will do in the future. Notice
how people flip out of the yield curve
becomes downward sloping. CNBC all they
can talk about is a recession is coming.
A recession is coming because you got a
downward sloping yield curve. It's
predicted 16 of the last three
recessions because you took a downward.
Oh my god, the recession is coming. For
the last 3 years, the yield curve has
been mostly downward sloping. Finally,
the recession is here. I'm sure this
will be put into recession predictor. It
has worked all the time, right? And this
is the problem with predictors. You give
yourself enough time, everything is a
predictor. But notice the correlation.
It's much weaker. So the level of the
interest rates clearly matter is the
slope of the income. But I wanted to use
this to actually look at stocks today
and say are stocks today correctly
priced. So here's what I did. I ran a
regression of earnings to price ratios
for US stocks. So this is called a time
series regression. Basically I'm looking
across time against the T- bond rate and
the difference between the T-bond rate
and the t rate. Let's read through the
coefficients. What does the intercept
tell you? Not much. It just says that's
my starting point. 3.41% 41% is my base
number for earnings to price. Every 1%
increase in the T- bond rate increases
the earnings to price ratio by
0.56%. Remember again increasing the
earnings price ratio means the price
earnings ratio decreases. I now have
given you a way of quantifying the
effect of what you think will happen to
T- bond rates next year. If you think T-
bond rates will drop by 1% over the next
year, that's going to translate into a
drop in the earnings to price ratio
of.56%.
which will translate into a higher P
ratio. Every 1% increase in the slope of
the U curve reduces the earnings to
price ratio
by.116%. But here's a cautionary note.
What's this in brackets below the
numbers? That's my t statistic, right?
What is a 008 t statistic tell
you? It really is not stat if I should
really rerun the regression and take out
the slope or the yield color. I left it
in there for a reason, but the truth is
if I'm making forecast, it's more noise
than than than an advantage to have it
in there. It doesn't seem to have any
explanatory power anymore. Say, what do
you mean anymore? It used to have
explanatory power. In 2008, you look at
the t statistic on that coefficient, it
was 1.46. In 2001, it was 2.53. Through
this century, that number has become
less and less
significant. And you know what this also
means, right? When you use the slope of
the yield curve to predict the economy,
you're basing it on on a 20th century
phenomenon where it seemed to do so.
What do you think's changed? Why has the
slope of the yield curve become a worse
predictor of what equities will do than
it used to be 25, 30, 50 years ago? What
is the slope? How does the yield curve
become down with sloping? What is the
phenomena that usually causes it to
happen? It's usually not long-term rates
collapsing. It's short-term rates rising
very quickly. Right? And historically,
what's caused short-term rates rise very
quickly? a central bank hitting the
brakes. Vulkar Paul Vulkar in know 1979
pushing up short-term rates of 14 15
16%. You know what that that's that that
yo me coefficient measures measures how
much central banks affect equity price.
Here's the strange
irony. 30 years ago people didn't talk
much about central banks. You didn't
even know probably a few people would
have known who the head of and the the
the head led the Fed. You couldn't name
a single other person on the on the
board, right? They were not visible.
They didn't talk. And central banks are
actually more influential. Now they're
all over the place. All people talk
about is Jerome Paul. What's he going to
do today? I think he had 11:30 a.m. and
everybody's waiting baited breath.
Jerome's going to save the world again.
Babies come out in the Superman outfits.
I'm going to say the word. The more
central banks become visible and
central, the less effect they seem to
have on markets. Now, let that kind of,
you know, bounce around your head. Maybe
the best central bankers are like, you
know, what they used to say for
children. You probably, you know, pulled
up for child abuse when you did that.
What do they say about children? They
should be seen and not heard, right? You
can't get away with that anymore.
Central bankers should be neither seen
nor hush. They should be like invisible
people, right? Because they seem to have
more influence when they're there and
you don't even know what they're doing,
but you just see the effects of their
actions. So maybe we're letting central
bankers kind of get in the way of their
own story. If you get a chance, what I'd
like you to do is take the T-bond rate
right now. I think today it dropped
below 4% for the first time in a long
time. Take the table rate right now.
Plug it into that regression. So use
this regression out there. See what you
get as a predicted earnings price ratio.
Say what am I going to do with that?
Let's say the earnings to price ratio
you come up with is 4.4%. How do I use
that? You invert it and you come up with
the P ratio. You look at the actual PE
ratio for better or worse you're getting
at least at a point in time is the
market cheap or expensive given its own
history and given what interest rates
look like today. It's actually very
useful in the periods where rates
dropped to explain why price earnings
ratio should be higher when the T- bond
rate was 2%. So the chilipe you know the
the panic that the chilipe created
especially in know
201617 18 all you had to do is plug it
into the plug in the interest rates and
much of that overpricing you saw by just
looking at the PE ratio kind of
dissipated so try it out see what you
find because next session we're going to
start on PEG ratios and we'll keep
moving I'll see you see you soon take
care oh on the quizzes I will let you
know when they're graded and you can
come pick them up. So sometime hopefully
tomorrow
different
All you have to
do is like the
Amazon Click on this.